(audience applauds)
- So we were both servers,
I found out, you were a server as well.
- Yep.
- I think all of,
were you a server?
- I was never a server.
- Oh my God, you're
the only actor--
- How much do you hate me?
- I've ever met--
- I know.
- That's never served a table.
- I've never had
another job.
(Kelly laughs)
I know, isn't that bad?
- Oh, that's so great
for you!
- That's kinda dope.
- That's an awesome, right?
- I envy you, yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like I've had
every job. (laughs)
- Yeah, same.
- I loved serving, actually.
Well, I was a cocktail waitress
and I felt like I was (fingers
snapping) pretty good at--
- [Cordae] Where did you serve at?
- A comedy club.
- Okay, dope.
- Yeah.
- Okay, good vibes,
good energy.
- Yeah, I know.
- It was happy, it was good.
- Yeah.
- Did you like serving, or no?
- Absolutely not, oh my God.
(everyone laughs)
- Man.
- You didn't?
I loved my friends I worked with.
I thought it was cool.
- Yeah, it was the restaurant
I was at, because I
was more than a server.
Sometimes I would have to cook.
If it was dessert--
- Oh.
- God forbid somebody ordered dessert.
I had to go in the back
and make it myself.
- What?
- For real,
like the frosting.
- Well, I didn't do that.
- I was my own busser.
I was the bus boy, I had
to bus my own tables.
I had to like scrape the--
- Was this at your house?
- Where the hell did you work?